Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es geht los mit unserer Ligatour. Heute wollen wir sprechen über die Liga in Frankreich, die Premier League in England und La Liga in Spanien mit drei Gästen, die ich euch gleich vorstelle, hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Hallo, schön, dass ihr drei hier seid. Zum einen David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 390. Hallo David. Hallo, außerdem mit dabei Uli Hebel von der Saunen und Neu. Jetzt gibt's ihn auch in Sky. Hallo Uli. Ich grüße. Und ebenfalls mit dabei Alex Truica. Ihr kennt ihn vom Tiki-Taka-Fußball-Podcast. Hallo Alex. So, wir wollen in einer Vierer-Runde über drei europäische Ligen sprechen. Und das Ganze soll es jetzt regelmäßiger geben. Das heißt, wir gehen ein bisschen weniger tief rein, aber hoffentlich wird die Schlagzahl ein bisschen höher für euch. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir probieren das mal aus. Ihr gebt uns einfach Feedback und dann schauen wir mal, wie uns allen das gefällt. Gehen wir gleich rein. Ach so, das Wortspiel Ligatour muss ich hoffentlich nicht erklären. Ansonsten googelt es an alle Typografie-Freunde da draußen. Es hat doch was mit Chirurgie zu tun. Ich meine aber das Wortspiel Typographel. So, jetzt muss man seine Wortspiele schon erklären. Es ist sehr früh. Wir beginnen mit der Ligue 1, denn da ist so einiges passiert. David, die Ligue 1 hat zum einen schon drei Spieltage hinter sich. Ich wollte dir eigentlich eine schöne Messi-Eingangsfrage stellen, aber da hat sich etwas in den Vordergrund geschoben. Beim Spiel zwischen Nizza und Olympique Marseille gestern Abend, und wir nehmen am Montag auf, kam es zu einem Spielabbruch. Während des gesamten Spiels sollen Gegenstände aus der Fankurve der Nizza-Fans auf Spieler von Olympique geworfen worden sein. Und als dann Dimitri Payet von einer Flasche getroffen wurde, feuerte er die zurück in die Zuschauer-Ränge. Es kam zu einem Platzsturm. Und hernach konnte man sehen, Marseille-Spieler wurden verletzt. Es gab Bilder auf Social Media zu sehen, bei denen man Würge-Male bei den Spielern erkennen konnte. Und es ist traurig, dass ich hier nicht übertreibe. Was war da los?
Ich glaube, da kann man der Situation gar nicht mehr viel hinzuzufügen. Payet wurde schon vorher beworfen, bei einer vorigen Ecke. Da habe ich Aufnahmen gesehen, das ist richtig. Und dann... Jetzt hast du mich rausgebracht.
Dadurch, dass ich dir jetzt schon alles vorweggenommen habe, indem ich es besprochen habe. Gibt es denn da eine besondere Revalität zwischen diesen beiden Mannschaften? Dass Olympique nicht die beliebteste Mannschaft in Frankreich ist, hat sicherlich auch historische Gründe. Aber gab es da eine Vorgeschichte, die ich jetzt nicht kenne?
Es gibt natürlich eine Realität, insofern, dass es in gewisser Weise ein Derby ist. Es sind zwei große Städte in Südfrankreich. Messi ist eine zweitgrößte Stadt, Nizza eine fünftgrößte Stadt. Es gibt historische, gewachsene Dinge. Nizza muss in der Region an Messi rapporten und so weiter. All das gibt es. Mein Eindruck ist, es ist mal wieder dieses typische, der Kleine ist ein bisschen sauerer auf den Größeren, als dass der Größere den etwas Kleineren tatsächlich wahrnimmt. Messi misst sich, glaube ich, lieber mit Paris historisch oder sieht sich eher als den Großen, während Nizza halt immer der kleine Nachbar ist. Und das hat die Fans, glaube ich, historisch schon immer besonders aufgestachelt. Also da ist eine gewisse Aggressivität drin. Jetzt muss man sagen, generell sind ja viele Fans, viele Ultras in Südfrankreich durchaus hitzig aggressiv. Also da nehmen sich die Marcel-Fans ja tatsächlich auch nichts. Und dann gibt es offenbar auch in den letzten Wochen, Monaten, Jahren immer wieder Probleme mit Schiedsrichtern, die halt solche Übergriffe auch nicht rechtzeitig ahnten. Also, zum Liga-Auftakt in Montpellier wurden sie bereits beworfen mit Flaschen. Da gibt es auch ein Foto, da hat ein Spieler eine Platzwunde bekommen an der Lippe. Ranjier war es, glaube ich. Dann haben halt die Marseille-Spieler gesagt, wir gehen da nicht mehr aus. Es gab auch noch Tumulte zwischen den Verantwortlichen der Clubs, zumindest zwischen einigen. Es gab eine Handgemenge zwischen José Cobos, der ist ein Verantwortlicher der Stadt Nizza, und Longoria, Präsident von Marseille, musste auch geschlichtet werden. Also, da war einiges im Argen. Und dann haben die Marseille Verantwortlichen gesagt, wir gehen da nicht mehr raus, während die Nizza-Spieler eben dann aufs Feld gegangen sind. Der Präsident mit den Ultras geredet hat, Polizei aufmarschiert ist und die Liga dann offenbar entschieden hat, nee, es ist jetzt alles unter Kontrolle, wir können da jetzt weitermachen. Das hat ziemlich lang gedauert, so eine Stunde etwa, konnte man das verfolgen. Kudos an den Moderator, der da jetzt eine Stunde überbrücken musste und Bilder kommentieren musste, wo es nicht viel zu sehen gab. Und am Ende kam es zu dieser etwas seltsamen Szene, dass der Ball noch mal zur Ecke hingelegt wurde, aber keine Marseillespieler auf dem Feld waren und dann der Schiedsrichter offiziell abgepfiffen hat. Das könnte man jetzt so werten, als dass die Liga sagt, der Marseille ja nicht mehr angetreten ist, wird es 0 zu 3 gegen Marseille gewettet. Man muss ja sagen, zu dem Zeitpunkt lag Nizza vorne. Die hatten ein richtig tolles Spiel gemacht, die haben sowieso einen ganz tollen Saisonstart. Die haben jetzt gegen Lille 4 zu 0 gewonnen. Die haben den ehemaligen Meister Lille 4 zu 0 abgefertigt, haben ja ihren Meistertrainer abgeworben, Galtier und Nizza hat wirklich eine ganz spannende Mannschaft da aufgezogen. Insofern ist das erstmal auch alles sehr traurig und ärgerlich für den Fußball. Jedenfalls, was ich gerade sagen wollte, aktuell, heute Morgen, um Montagmorgen, ist aktuell nicht klar, wie das jetzt gewertet wird. Ob das jetzt ein 0 zu 3 im grünen Teppich für Nizza ist, ob da jetzt Marseille klagt und es da noch ein 0 zu 3 für Marseille ist, weil Nizza seine Fans nicht an der Kontrolle hatte, weiß keiner. Also müssen wir abwarten, aber Fakt ist, dieses Spiel wird vermutlich irgendwie am grünen Tisch entschieden werden und das ist eigentlich ziemlich schade. Wie gesagt, das war bis dahin ein ziemlich spannendes Spiel. Nizza hat stark eingekauft, wie ich den Eindruck habe. Die haben ein ganz starkes Mittelfeld mit Pablo Rosario und Mario Lemina. Die haben so eine Flügelzange mit Rosario und Stengs, aus Niederländischen Spielern. Die haben Patrick Kloybert geholt und die haben ganz, ganz starke...
Also bei ihnen spielt auch noch Dante. Also Patrick Kloybert hätte mich jetzt auch komplett gewundert.
Genau, Dante spielt auch noch damit und war ja gestern auch mal wieder sehr aktiv im Schlichten. Also da auch wieder Hut ab an ihn, ist nach wie vor ein toller Charakter.
Caspar Dolberg noch, der auch gestern dann an zu Null getroffen hat. Also da wäre quasi sportlich einiges zu holen. Wie das jetzt entschieden wird, das werden dann die Hörerinnen und Hörer wahrscheinlich selbst mitbekommen. Da wird Großtüper berichtet, aber deswegen mussten wir jetzt auch damit starten. So haben wir uns die Rückkehr von Fans nicht vorgestellt. Das waren wirklich unschöne Szenen. Dann lass aber dann bei den Sportlichen die sportliche Kurve bekommen. Wir müssen ja auch über Lionel Messi sprechen, wobei der konnte jetzt noch nicht so wirklich in Aktion treten. Ist es nicht ein bisschen ironisch, dass du uns in 3.90 über die letzten 1,5 Jahre hinweg erklärt hast, wie schwer es war für die Liga, die Fernsehrechte zu vermarkten und wie man da Einbußen nach Einbußen hinnehmen musste? Und dann kommt einer, wenn nicht sogar vielleicht der größte Fußballspieler der Welt in diese Liga?
Ja, und ich glaube, es ist auch immer noch ein bisschen schwer zu fassen eigentlich. Selbst für Leute, die die Liga jetzt verfolgen, dass da tatsächlich Messi spielt. Man wusste ja schon immer, dass Paris ein bisschen größer wahnsinnig ist, dass sie da das ganze Katar-Geld haben und sich theoretisch irgendwie sicherlich jeden Spieler der Welt hätten kaufen können. Aber dass das jetzt tatsächlich klappt, dass die Situation so hinläuft, dass da Barcelona sich von Messi trennt und dann niemand anderes gerade bereitsteht außer Paris. Die sagen, ja gut, wir können deinen Gehalt bezahlen. Das ist schon ein bisschen, das ist nach wie vor eigentlich seltsam. Und wie du das vielleicht sagst, noch ist er nicht aufgetreten. Also das ganze Land wartet immer noch darauf, dass er zum ersten Mal wirklich real, physisch auf einem Platz von, weiß ich nicht wo, an einem regnerischen Sonntagabend in Rance auf dem Platz steht.
Ich glaube, fassbarer wird es wirklich, wenn er dann tatsächlich sein Debüt feiert. Genau. Dann wird es eher greifbarer, dann realisiert man es noch mehr.
Genau.
Denn bisher ist es wirklich ein bisschen unglaublich im wahrsten Sinne.
Genau, genau, genau. Und dann wird auch klar, wie PSG überhaupt auftreten will, in welcher Formation. Uli, du hast das Spiel ja kommentiert. PSG gegen Brest, das ist ja gesehen. Das ist alles noch, also auf mich wirkt das alles noch sehr Stückwerk. Da spielen immer noch auch Spieler mit, die sicherlich nicht in der ersten Elf in der Champions League spielen werden. Und man fragt sich tatsächlich so ein bisschen, wo will jetzt da Pochettino hin? Wie kriegt er das unter Kontrolle? Der wird sicherlich Streits oder Egos zu schlichten haben. Noch ein Nöcher. Das fängt jetzt schon an mit Donnar Romau und Navas. Navas ist eine sehr, sehr einflussreiche Person in der Kabine. Der wird jetzt nicht einfach so seinen Platz räumen, wobei er jetzt auch nicht komplett fehlerlos war die ersten Spiele. Und dann hast du halt den Man of the Europameisterschaft im Nacken. Und das kannst du jetzt an mehreren Stellen durchdeklinieren. Also da müssen Leute auf die Bank oder müssen halt in der Liga gegen kleine Vereine spielen, während die anderen in der Champions League auftreten dürfen. Das wird sehr spannend.
Uli, du hast das Spiel kommentiert. 4 zu 2 bei Brest, also der vierte Torfiel ist in der 90. Minute. In der 85. gab es noch den 3 zu 2 Anschlusstreffer. Und dadurch, dass PSG jetzt noch mehr der Favorit ist als in den Jahren zuvor, drücken natürlich viele den Außenseitern dann die Daumen. Welchen Eindruck hat PSG auf dich gemacht aus sportlicher Sicht?
Nicht gut, wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin. Weil das 3-3 durchaus nahe war. Und ich hatte eigentlich gedacht, dass es so kommt. Jetzt muss man, glaube ich, Parisianer mal in Offensive und Defensive teilen. Das ist, glaube ich, auch im Kader gar nicht anders zu machen. Ansonsten, die Offensive ist natürlich individuell top besetzt. Da habt ihr ja auch schon drüber geredet. Ob sich das dann so aufteilen lässt, ist die große Frage. Wenngleich, das gebe ich ja auch noch mal mit dazu, wir, glaube ich, müssen nicht mit Neymar planen, dass der mehr als 25 Spiele in der Saison macht. Muss er jetzt auch nicht mehr, ist vielleicht auch ganz gut so. Da sind ein paar, die nicht in Form sind. Messi ist jetzt auch nicht mehr der Allerjüngste, auch wenn er keine große Verletzungshistorie hat. Das heißt, da habe ich noch ein gewisses Vertrauen hin. Aber die Restverteidigung ist mitunter gruselig. Also da bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt, wenn dann inklusive Hakimi als Rechtsverteidiger sieben bis acht Leute nach vorne stürmen. Dann gibt es halt wahnsinnig viele Räume. Und jetzt ist natürlich Brest vielleicht noch so nicht in der Lage, das auszunutzen, wobei sie es ja auch schon wirklich vier, fünfmal richtig gut gemacht haben. Aber das gucke ich mir an in der Champions League gegen Teams, die mehrheitlich natürlich jetzt auch vom Umschalten leben und insbesondere gegen Paris aufs Umschalten setzen werden. Das gucke ich mir an. Also ich bin noch nicht restlos überzeugt. Wenn ich da dazwischengrätschen darf, ich glaube, die Messi-Sache wird sehr, sehr spannend zu sehen sein, wie Paris seine Einsatzminuten, seine Einsatzzeiten steuert. Denn Messi ist es aus Barcelona nicht gewohnt, nicht zu spielen. Er hat seit Jahren immer jedes Spiel absolviert. Er bekommt wirklich nie Pausen, sondern nimmt sich selbst Pausen auf dem Spielfeld, wo er halt einfach mal 20 Minuten nicht nach hinten arbeitet. Und ich glaube, bei PSG wirst du eher in diese Rotation kommen, dass du sagst, wie bei Neymar jetzt gegen Brest oder gegen Valenciennes oder wie auch immer am Wochenende, da schonen wir dich mal. Ob Messi das damit umgehen kann, ob sein Körper damit auch umgehen kann. Denn er ist es nicht gewohnt zu pausieren. Er spielt im Dreitagesrhythmus seit vielen, vielen Jahren bei Barca. Also das bin ich gespannt zu sehen, wie da die Belastungssteuerung sein wird und wie der Spieler auch damit umgehen kann.
Aber das ist natürlich auch noch mal ein spannender Punkt, mit dem Mit-Nach-Zurück-Arbeiten. Weil wenn du jetzt einen, also die Franzosen haben es ja bereits den M&M-Sturm genannt, Messi Neymar im Barpé hast, da ist Neymar auch schon in der Liga nie dafür bekannt gewesen, dass er mit nach hinten arbeitet.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, das hört sich natürlich an.
M&M-P hat das teilweise durchaus gemacht, aber jetzt auch nicht immer. Und wenn natürlich dann drei Superstars haben, die da vorne bleiben, huiuiui, da bin ich, also da bin ich wirklich mal gespannt, was das gibt.
Also ich glaube, in der Liga wird es sich eher nicht rechnen. Da wird es sich eher nicht unbedingt negativ darstellen, denn sie sollten die Liga so oder so gewinnen. Spannend ist es natürlich dann in der Champions League, wenn es dann wirklich hart auf hart kommt gegen richtige Gegner, die vielleicht noch mal zehn Prozent mehr motiviert sind. Also in der Liga glaube ich, können Mbappé, Neymar und Messi vorne stehen bleiben und es sollte trotzdem locker reichen, um ehrlich zu sein. Ohne jetzt zu despektierlich gegenüber der Liga sein zu wollen.
Ja, wobei PSG auch, das hätte man ja letztes Jahr schon sagen können, allein mit Neymar und Mbappé und dem Kader. Und trotzdem haben sie letztes Jahr ja immer wieder auch Punkte liegen lassen und sich ja auch die Meisterschaft wegnehmen lassen.
Ja gut, gehören halt noch andere Mannschaften dazu, über die wir gleich noch sprechen werden. Das ist vielleicht dann das Problem. Aber ich möchte noch einmal ganz kurz Uli eine Frage stellen. Du hast gesagt, du glaubst, Neymar wird nicht mehr als 25 Spiele machen. Warum? Also, weil er nicht möchte, weil er nicht darf. Also wie hast du das gemeint?
Wenn man sich einfach nur mal anguckt, was die Statistiken der letzten Jahre sagen, dann war er doch mehrheitlich zu einem guten Drittel der Saison raus. Und ich gehe jetzt nicht davon aus, dass sich das ändern wird. Und es muss sich vielleicht auch gar nicht ändern. Vielleicht ist es auch einfach gut für einen Spieler wie ihn, genau so was zu schneidern, dass du ihn dann in den Spielen hast, in denen du ihn brauchst. Weil ich glaube, der hat fast schon Imageprobleme inzwischen. Der ist ein wirklicher echter Unterschiedsspieler gewesen in den Champions-League-Spielzeiten der vergangenen Jahre. Vielleicht ist es gut, dass du ihn dann einfach gesund im März, April hast. Jetzt brauchst du ihn gegen Dijon oder Brest vielleicht noch nicht unbedingt.
Stimmt, das war mir so gar nicht bewusst. Ich hab's mal gerade nachgeguckt. Die Spiele in den letzten vier Ligue 1-Saisons, also in allen vier Ligue 1-Saisons von Neymar, er ist nie über 20 Spiele gekommen. Und das in einer 20-Mannschaften-Liga, liebe Hörer. Wir haben 38 Spieltage. Er hat 18, 15, 17 und 20 Spiele gemacht. In seiner Debüt-Saison waren es mit 20 noch die allermeisten. Da hat er auch die meisten Treffer erzielt. Stimmt, das hatte ich sogar nicht auf dem Schirm.
Wie schätzt denn eigentlich Real die Chance, einen Mbappé noch zu bekommen, Alex?
Ich glaube, da ist man tatsächlich ziemlich zuversichtlich, was eher an Kollegen Mbappé liegt, denn an PSG. PSG will logischerweise keinesfalls abgeben, El Khalifi. Er stemmt sich da ja dagegen. Aber ich glaube, Mbappés Schweigen allein schon wird halt sehr positiv aufgenommen bei Real oder interpretiert. Denn er bindet sich ja nicht an PSG unbedingt verbal. Er sagt, er macht ja da keine klaren Aussagen. Von wegen, mir gefällt es hier super. Und natürlich möchte ich jetzt hier alles erreichen. Die ist das. Da gibt es ja nichts.
Da hat man sich ja nicht verlängert.
Verlängert hat er auch nicht, aber es ist ja auch nur Schweigen. Es berät das Schweigen, wie man so schön sagt, glaube ich. Also ich glaube, da ist was im Busch. Ich kann euch aus erster Hand sagen, wenn ich es kurz einwerfen darf. Aus erster Hand? Das ist aber hoffentlich nicht zurückzuverfolgen, sonst wird es bitter für mich. Wir sind ja unter uns. Genau, das hört ja niemand. Dass er schon länger klargemacht hat, dass er da nicht verlängern will und wird. Und wenn jemand bezahlen könnte, wäre er längst weg. Und der Einzige, bei dem man es sich vorstellen kann, dass sie in irgendeiner Weise irgendeinen Konstrukt hinbekommen, legal oder nicht legal, ist Real Madrid.
Ich könnte mir allerdings schon auch vorstellen, dass Paris vielleicht trotzdem sagt, naja, diese Chance, diesen Supersturm zumindest ein Jahr lang zu haben, lassen wir uns nicht entgehen. Und notfalls lassen wir den Vertrag halt auslaufen, weil was kümmern uns da die 180 Millionen, die wir gezahlt haben? Andererseits natürlich können auch sie durchaus in the long run für die Bilanzen etc., für diverse Regularien, sei es Liga, sei es UEFA, Geld gebrauchen.
Gibt es da welche, ja?
Das sagt hier der Spanien-Experte. Also wie kann sich denn bitte Real Mbappé leisten? Was ist denn hier los?
Die haben, glaube ich, sogar Plus gemacht. Oh, Herr Hamilchen.
Geht das überhaupt?
Na ja, das ist tatsächlich in der Corona-Pandemie-Zeit außergewöhnlich, ne?
Ach so, ich dachte Transparenz.
Selbst sehr vernünftig geführte Vereine, BVB etc., kriegen das ja nicht hin. Also Real hat ein minimales Plus gemacht. Das ist wirklich außergewöhnlich. Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass man sich ein Pape davon leisten kann. Aber zumindest sind sie nicht ganz so schlecht aufgestellt wie manch anderer Verein, der prominent in der Liga spielt.
Na ja, wir sprechen gleich nur über Barca.
Tatsächlich glaube ich sogar, dass PSG sogar ein bisschen hofft, dass sie mit Messi ein Pape eher dazu bringen können, noch weiter dazubleiben, weil er einfach Bock darauf hat, in so einer geilen Mannschaft zu spielen. Der muss sich auch durchaus, wie so ein Kind, diebisch geäußert haben gegenüber seinen Freunden, wow, schaut mal, Messi hier und so. Also, nach dem ersten Training, da scheinen einige Spieler im Kader, die jetzt nicht näher namentlich genannt worden sind, die in der Vergangenheit eher gedacht haben, sie wollen gehen, scheinen jetzt noch mal zu denken, na ja, also bei dem Projekt will ich jetzt noch mal mit einem Jahr dabei sein, weil das könnte etwas sein, von dem noch die Geschichtsbücher schreiben. Ich bin aber tatsächlich ähnlich wie Uli auch noch so ein bisschen skeptisch, muss ich sagen, weil ich habe das Gefühl, die schlurfen noch gerade so ein bisschen durch die Liga. Und das kann durchaus auch noch mal nach hinten losgehen.
Ich glaube, der Spieler sollte man auch nie außen vor lassen, da ist ja auch jedes anders. Also der eine Spieler freut sich natürlich auf einen Spieler wie Messi, da ist die Chance der Karriere mit so jemanden zusammenspielen. Gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich Egos, die sagen, naja, jetzt stehe ich nicht mehr so im Scheinwerferlicht, darf vielleicht die Elfmeter oder Freistöße nicht schießen, alles fokussiert sich medial auf Messi. Und das gefällt vielleicht dem einen oder anderen nicht. Also da ist ja auch jeder anders. Neymar ist ja damals vor wieviel, vier Jahren, gewechselt, weil er im Schatten Messis stand und daraus raustreten wollte. Jetzt natürlich nach ein paar Jahren hat er es bereut, jetzt möchte er mit seinem Kumpel wieder zusammenspielen, aber da ist ja auch nicht jeder gleich. Also es kann auch sein, dass ein Papet sagt, na ja, okay, jetzt bin ich nicht mehr so die Nummer 1B oder 1A in Paris. Und vielleicht gefällt ihm das auch nicht. Also das war ja schon so, neymar, so, ne? Dass er durchaus gefordert hat, ich muss minimum gleiches Gehalt bekommen, ich muss minimum selben Zugang für die Entourage bekommen, ich muss minimum auch so viel Gewicht im Mannschaftsbus haben. Also es ist nicht so für die Kabine, sondern der Bus, wo gesungen und gebetet wird. Also das ist schon etwas, das ihn sowieso schon umgetrieben hat. Ich glaube auch, ich habe auch ähnliche Dinge gelesen, tatsächlich, dass Mbappé auch deswegen zu Real will, weil Real dann sein Team ist. Benzema ist 34, Modric 35, einen wirklich zweiten Star gibt es ja eh nicht bei Real aktuell, wirklich mit Hazard funktioniert ja nicht seit seinem Wechsel. Da wäre er halt die absolute Nummer eins in jeglicher Hinsicht, sportlich, vom Standing her, vom Marketing her, von medialen Aufmerksamkeit her. Und ich hab das Gefühl persönlich, dass gefällt Mbappé schon auch so.
Ja klar, das war ja auch die Kommunikation von PSG, dass sie gesagt haben, wir wollen da ein Projekt um ihn herum aufbauen. Also das ist ja auch aus französischer Sicht nochmal erst recht nicht verwunderlich, also deinen eigenen französischen Superstar im eigenen Land zu haben für den Hauptstadtclub. Klar kann man jetzt sich auch aus der Sicht fragen, ja, ist es jetzt gut, dass Messi kommt, weil es stärkt deine Chancen, die Champions League zu gewinnen, oder ist es dann doch widersprüchlich, dass du sagst, wir wollen ein Projekt um dich aufbauen und setzen ja noch jemanden mit rein? Für Paris, keine Ahnung, dann tauscht er den möglichen kommenden Superstar der nächsten Generation ein gegen einen älteren Spieler. Ja, ja, da liegen ganz viele Fragen rum.
Es schmälert übrigens die Chancen auf den Weltfußballer-Titel von Mbappé, der Messi-Wechsel. Denn ganz ehrlich, wenn PSG die Champions League gewinnt, man kann sich vorstellen, wer dann eher im Scheinwerfer-Licht steht.
Also, ich muss jetzt, es tut mir leid, ich muss jetzt die Sertoramus-Geräte ansetzen. Also, bevor wir jetzt hier in unserer wertvollen Zeit über den Weltfußballer-Titel sprechen, der interessiert wirklich nur die, die ihn gewinnen können, nee, dann, dann, dann, tut mir leid, muss ich jetzt dazwischengrätschen, das geht nicht. Da gibt's jetzt den Ellbogenschlag von mir, lass dich mal lieber auf Geschirrnasschütterungen untersuchen, Alex, nach dieser Sendung. Wir müssen nämlich definitiv auch noch über jene Mannschaften sprechen, die in der letzten Saison konstant gut waren und deshalb auch letztlich PSG nicht Meister werden konnte. Allen voran natürlich Lille, der Meister. Denn für die läuft's alle ganz, ganz fürchterlich. Also Olympique, Lyon, zwei Punkte erst. Lille auch erst zwei Punkte. Zwei Unentschieden, eine Niederlage. Monaco sogar nur ein Punkt. Ein Unentschieden und zwei Niederlagen. Das läuft ja ganz hervorragend für alle Konkurrenten von PSG.
Mit Ausnahm von Marseille. Wobei auch so halbwegs nur. Ja, genau, die großen Schwächeln alle total. Hat jeweils ein bisschen unterschiedliche Gründe. Also Lille haben natürlich ihren Meistertrainer verloren mit Galtier, der dann eben jetzt zu Nizza abgewandert ist. Angeblich gibt es da immer noch intern Trouble und Streit wegen der nicht ausgezahlten Meisterprämie, die sich der Club nicht leisten konnte. Die spielen auch alle ein bisschen gefrustet im Sinne von, wir sind Meister geworden, aber weder haben wir jetzt die tollen Verträge bei anderen gelandet, noch haben wir besseres Galt. Die haben sich jetzt ein bisschen berappelt am letzten Spieltag, sind wieder ein bisschen bissiger geworden. Lyon hat so sein ganz eigenes Problem, weil die wollten ja endlich mal einen Welttrainer haben, einen großen Trainer von Format mit innovativen Ideen. Und dann haben sie sich Bosch geholt.
Sorry, es war respektierlich, dass ich gelacht habe, aber...
Ja, die Berichterstattung war jetzt für jemanden, der die Bundesliga verfolgt hat, tatsächlich so ein bisschen surreal, weil tatsächlich im Vorfeld ganz, ganz viel von dem Projekt und dem neuen innovativen Fußball und so weiter geredet wurde. Und die ersten Spieltage sind jetzt schon das, was man als jemand, der Bundesliga verfolgt hat, erwarten könnte. Also ja, Bosz predigt einen intensiven, spannenden Fußball, der toll aussieht, wenn er funktioniert oder funktionieren würde. Aber funktioniert aktuell nicht. Und die Mannschaft wirkt sehr zerfasert, weiß teilweise nicht genau, was sie eben machen soll. Und ist hinten offen wie ein Scheunentor, hat sich jetzt gegen Clemence, in der 80. Minute, haben sie 3 zu 1 geführt, haben sich noch das 3 zu 3 angefangen.
Clemence, Aufsteiger.
Clemence, Aufsteiger, müssen wir gleich noch was dazu sagen. Kurz 2, 3 Sätze, bevor du mich dann abwirkst mit der Viertelstunde, die ich überzogen hab.
Den Ruf hast du jetzt übrigens weg, ne?
Aber jetzt weht hier ein anderer Ton im Rasenfunk.
Also klar haben sie Depay verloren, der wirklich ein top und überragender Spieler ist, dessen Ruf möglicherweise auch gar nicht so sehr über die Ligue 1 hinausgekommen ist. Können wir ja auch... Der ist ja jetzt anderswo. Aber das allein kann nicht der Grund sein. Und Monaco steh ich auch so ein bisschen vorm Rätsel, weil Monaco ist eigentlich zusammengehalten, geblieben geworden. Da ist dieselbe Struktur wie vorher da. Kovac hat ein tolles System etabliert, die haben ja super Aufholjagd gestartet in der Rückrunde und aktuell geht man denen gar nicht zusammen. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit da eine Rolle spielt, dass sie aktuell noch durch die Champions-League-Quali sich müssen. Gegen Prag hat es jetzt funktioniert, gegen Donetsk liegen sie aktuell 0-1 im Hinspiel zurück. In den Playoffs, ob sie sich dazu sehr darauf konzentrieren. Das Mittelfeld scheint ein bisschen müde. Mittelfeld war ganz, ganz imminent wichtig in der Rückrunde mit Fofana und Xumeni. Da läuft aktuell der Kovac-Fußball auch nicht. Die kreieren sich viele Chancen, machen nichts rein. Oder jetzt, wie am letzten Spieltag, noch nicht mal nennenswerte Chancen gegen Lens. Die haben alle so ihr eigenes Päckchen. Dagegen hast du plötzlich neue Teams, Aufsteiger, die richtig mutig reinspielen. Die Trainer haben, die sagen Nein. Hinten reinstellen ist nicht unser Ziel. Wir wollen durchaus mit dem weitermachen, wie wir in der zweiten Liga erfolgreich waren. Weil alles andere nützt eh nichts. Du hast mit Clermont ein... Ich muss noch mal schauen, wo stehen die jetzt?
Vierter, es ist jetzt gerade alles ein bisschen schwierig, weil nicht klar ist, wie man das Nizza-Spiel werten wird. Also je nachdem, wie man Nizza wertet.
Also Clermont ist ein Club, der war in den 40er-Jahren erstklassig und danach nie wieder. Und die 40er-Jahre, da kann man auch kurz ausklimmern, weil da fanden so Notmeisterschaften wegen des Krieges statt. Die hatten in der 2. Liga das 11. größte Budget. Die sind eventuell dem einen oder anderen schon mal aufgefallen in den vergangenen Jahren, weil sie 2014 der Verein war, der mit Corinne Diacre, die erste Frau als Trainerin eines Profiklubs engagiert hat.
Danke, jetzt weiß ich endlich, warum bei Clermont immer so ein ganz kleines Glöckchen klingelt.
Genau, was ja auch eine richtig erfolgreiche Zeit war, die war ja dann bester Zweitligatrainerin des Jahres, ist dann abgeworben worden, leider, muss man fast sagen, zur Frauen-Nationalmannschaft. Und ja, also die verstecken sich nicht. Die führen aktuell die Statistik der herausgespielten Chancen an. Außen gehen immer schön mit nach vorne, Innenverteidiger rücken mit auf. Klar sind sie auch anfällig, aber bislang, Auftaktsieg gegen Bordeaux 2-0, Troyes 2-0 ist ein Mitaufsteiger. Und jetzt eben dieses 3-3 gegen Lyon. Also die stehen da aktuell durchaus zurecht um. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass sie da bis Ende der Saison stehen bleiben, aber du hast insgesamt eine ganze Menge an Trainern, das ist auch durchaus nicht ganz so gewöhnlich für die Liga, du hast eine ganze Menge an Trainern, die einen durchaus offensiven, ambitionierten Fußball wollen. Also Petkovic könnte man kurz noch mal erwähnen, der bei Bordeaux jetzt mit neu dazugekommen ist. Klar, Kovac prinzipiell auch und Galtier. Entschuldigung, irgendjemand wollte gerade was sagen.
Nein, nein, alles gut. Also ich sehe schon, neben PSG kann man durchaus wieder andere Teams sehen in der Ligue 1. Deswegen ist es ja gut, dass man viel davon bei der Zone präsentiert bekommt. Also Klamot hatte ich jetzt auch noch nicht so auf dem Zettel. Da habe ich jetzt Lücken nachzuarbeiten. Danke dir, lieber David. Jetzt ist der Moment gekommen, wo ich dich abwürge. Ich hoffe, ich habe es wenigstens halbwegs charmant hinbekommen. Ach man, mich nervt mein eigenes Format jetzt schon. Aber wir können ja gerne zwei Stunden reden. Ihr müsst ja auch noch andere Dinge tun. Deswegen lasst uns jetzt über die Premier League sprechen. Uli, dafür bist du ja so ein bisschen hier in dieser Runde mit dabei, wobei du ja schon gezeigt hast, du kannst sowieso bei allem mitreden. Das finde ich sehr angenehm. In der Premier League ist es nicht ganz so wie in der Ligue 1, dass man sich die Tabelle anguckt, wenn auch erst nach zwei Spieltagen und sagt, was ist denn hier passiert? Bei der Premier League ist alles genau wie immer. Brighton auf 3, Arsenal auf 19. Und ansonsten die üblich Verrechtigen. Nein, da habe ich jetzt schon die beiden Ausnahmen herausgenommen. Chelsea, Liverpool und Tottenham jeweils mit einem perfekten Start. Manchester City zwar einmal verloren zum Auftakt, allerdings war das Spiel auch sehr dominant geführt. Deutet sich irgendwie an, dass in der Premier League Lehmann, der sonst traditionell in dem Big Six stark ist, eine Schwäche haben könnte?
Also jetzt die Definitionsfrage, ob Arsenal da noch reingehört. Ich glaube sportlich schon eine Weile nicht mehr, finanziell. Und das ist natürlich mehrheitlich die Definitionsgrundlage.
Wahrscheinlich schon noch.
Ich rechne nicht damit, dass Arsenal eine Chance hat, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Das klingt ja ganz vielversprechend. Andererseits, gegen Chelsea kann man ja auch mal verlieren. Woher kommt dein Pessimismus? Kommt es aus der Brentford-Niederlage oder aus der Tottenhelm?
Ja, auch vom Spielplan her gesehen auch, weil nächster Gegner ist Manchester City. Da werde ich auch für verantwortlich sein für das Spiel. Freue mich schon sehr. Könnte aber auch sein, dass sie nach drei Spielen mit null Punkten dastehen. Grundsätzlich, das ist etwas Grundsätzliches bei Arsenal, dass ich das Gefühl habe, wir müssen gar nicht so sehr über taktische Dinge reden oder über Ausführungen auf dem Platz. Sondern das körperliche Grundniveau der Mannschaft ist erschreckend. Ich verstehe es nicht, dass die nach 40 Minuten schon platt wirken und nicht mehr tun können, was Arteta gerne hätte, oder zumindest was ich denke, dass er gerne hätte. Auch Arteta hat sich in meinem Bild drastisch gewandelt. Ich habe die ersten 60 Spiele in der Premier League gemacht und die ersten 20 dachte ich, das ist genau der Richtige. Dann habe ich weitere 20 gezweifelt und jetzt bin ich mir seit 20 fast sicher, dass das nichts werden kann. Die Prognose bei Arsenal ist nicht gut. Ich glaube nicht mal, dass sie die 8 noch matchen können vom Vorjahr, obwohl sie gut eingekauft haben. Was heißt gut? Sie haben viel Geld ausgegeben. Ich habe übrigens eine furchtbare Statistik gelesen. Arteta hat in 20 Monaten genauso viele Heimspiele verloren mit Arsenal wie Arsene Wenger in 6 Jahren. Er hat die 20. Niederlage im 60. Spiel kassiert. Wenger hat 116 für 20 Niederlagen gebraucht. Das ist das Bittere, die Wenger-Zeit. Das muss allen Garners-Fans und Anhängerinnen klar werden. Die ist vorbei. Die ist einfach gnadenlos vorbei. Die war ja auch in den letzten drei Jahren vorbei. Er wurde ja viel zu spät entlassen. Jetzt kommt Arthelter um die Ecke und hat in so kurzer Zeit eine viel schlechtere Heimbilanz. Das ist schon erschreckend. Jetzt kommt der Fakt, Arsene hat unter Emery noch nicht mal die Europa League gewonnen. Damit weißt du, wie mies es aussieht. Schön noch einen mitgeben, jawohl, den Arsenal-Fans.
Es klappt wirklich gar nichts. Obwohl man so viel investiert, das fand ich als jemand, der das immer nur aus dem Augenwinkel mitbekommt, weil er sich so auf die Bundesliga fokussiert, durchaus überraschend. Da hat Arsene richtig hingelangt. Unter anderem als zuletzt für Martin Oedegaard von Real Madrid. Aber wenn du sagst, es liegt an grundsätzlichen Dingen, glaubst du, das ist eine Diagnose, wie sie auch bei Arsene gestellt wird? Oder wie schätzen die das ein?
Also, man hört es jetzt auch von den Spielern, Obermian soll gerade richtig unglücklich sein. Ich glaube schon, dass die das alle begreifen, dass das gerade nicht geht. Ich weiß nur nicht genau, da komme ich nicht drauf, woran es liegt. Das ist ja, wenn man so will, eines der guten Dinge an Arsene, dass auch von der Führungsrieke her wenig gesprochen wird, da kommt wenig raus. Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, ist das eine Trainersache? Ist das eine Spieler-Qualitätssache? Ist das eine Führungssache, weil man mit den Krönkes nicht so ganz glücklich ist? Per Mertesager hat mir gesagt, das ist gar nicht so, sondern die Krönkes sind wirklich, man sagt in England immer hands-on, also die sind wirklich am Verein dran und die sprechen, die sprechen halt nur nicht nach außen. Und das kommt halt nicht raus. Es ist für mich wahnsinnig schwierig zu sagen. Was man aber sehen kann, ist, in diesen ganzen Jahren und die letzten drei, vier Wenger-Jahre zählen mit dazu, es ist kontinuierlich abwärts gegangen. Es ist immer ein Spieler weggegangen, den man so nicht hat ersetzen können und dann noch einer. Und dann kam ein junger raus, aber der hat nicht so durchgebrochen, wie man das gewohnt war. So ist irgendwann mal so ein schleichender, aber kontinuierlicher Qualitätsabfall da. Das ist jetzt dann so, wie es ist. Dazu kommen andere Teams, die halt reindrücken in diese ominöse Big Six, die bessere Arbeit, kontinuierliche Arbeit machen, besseres Recruitment haben und offensichtlich auch die Grundtugenden besser hinbekommen. Dann ist es so, wie es ist.
Wer sind denn da für dich diejenigen, die früher nicht zu den Top Six gehört haben und jetzt aber da reindrücken?
Also vor allen Dingen Leicester, halte ich für einen richtigen Geheimtipp. Das ist jetzt so geheim, das ist ja auch gar nicht mehr. Die haben letztes Jahr im Pokal gewonnen. Wir haben mit Brendan Rodgers einen der, wie ich finde, besten Trainer. Das ist 100 Prozent ein Team, das auch wieder um die Top-Six kämpfen wird. West Ham, auch wenn ich es nicht gedacht hätte. Die leisten großartige Arbeit. Oder David Mois seit guten eineinhalb Jahren. Bei Villa bin ich gespannt, wie es ohne Jack Grealish aussehen wird. Aber das Geld ist da. Die Besitzer dort haben nichts anderes vor, als groß zu werden in der Liga. Mal gucken, was Everton unter Rafa Benitez macht. Das sind die Teams, die wirklich dran stehen.
Und wie ist dann die Situation bei den großen Sechs selbst? Es scheint wunderbar zu laufen. Wir haben auch hier einen viel zitierten und beachteten Transfer beim FC Chelsea, Romelu Lukaku. Er darf jetzt dort spielen, ist zurückgekehrt. Er hat jetzt im Spiel gegen Arsenal gezeigt, warum er ihn verpflichtet hat. Damit hat Thomas Thore noch mal eine ganz andere Variante für den Sturm bekommen. Mit Favorit sind sie ja vorher auch schon gewesen durch den Champions-League-Sieg. Aber wie groß schätzt du die Chancen ein? Wir hatten ja ein Duo aus Liverpool und City. Das wurde dann ein bisschen aufgebrochen. Wird es jetzt wieder ein Mehrkampf werden in der Saison?
Das glaube ich schon. Ich würde Liverpool leicht rausrechnen aus den Top-Mannschaften. Ich glaube, ich habe Chelsea und City noch eins stärker. Und das liegt schon auch vor allen Dingen bei Chelsea dran, dass sie mit Lukaku jetzt eine ganz andere Möglichkeit haben. Es gab ja gestern schon diese Statistik 22 progressive Bälle. Das ist ja was, wo Thomas Thore wahnsinnig Wert darauf legt, die Impact-Bälle, sprich die Bälle, die wahnsinnig viel Raumgewinn erzielen oder Linien brechen. Und 22 von denen hat er gestern alleine verarbeiten können. Da sind noch nicht die eingerechnet, die er nicht hat festmachen können. Dazu schon getroffen. Und ich weiß, dass das Tuchel... Die einzige Schwäche, die Tuchel hat, und das wissen wir jetzt nun wirklich alle, ist die des fehlenden Top-Stürmers. Die ist jetzt adressiert worden. Und das mit dem absoluten Wunschspieler, den er immer wollte, das war nie Haaland, sondern das war immer Lukaku. Und damit ist Chelsea jetzt nicht nur breit, sondern auch in der Spitze unheimlich stark. In der Qualität haben sie einen genauen Plan, den sie verfolgen, und haben jetzt einen, der diesen Plan ganz vorne aufnehmen kann. Also die habe ich ganz stark in der Saison.
Dann Manchester City, das würde jetzt niemanden überraschen, dass du die genannt hast. Da gab es ja auch noch einige Veränderungen. Die Premier League war ja eine der Ligen, oder die beteiligten Vereine, besser gesagt, die sehr, sehr viel noch investieren konnten, auch in diesem Corona-Jahr. Wie ist da so die Gesamtsituation, auch wenn es eine Auftaktniederlage gab?
Ich glaube grundsätzlich gut, weil da ein Transfer noch nicht mit einberechnet ist, mit dem ich aber festrechne, nämlich der Harry Canes. Ich gehe davon aus, dass sie den noch dazu fügen werden. Und das ist dann auch dort die einzige vorhandene Schwäche, auch wenn es jetzt nicht so außer gegen Neuschweig gab, weil Gabriel Jesus das echt überragend gemacht hat als Vorbereiter, aber eben nicht so sehr als abschließender Spieler, wenn die noch einen richtigen Neuner dazu addieren. Und ich mir dann überlege, wie City gespielt hat, so von Mitte Dezember bis in etwa Mitte März, April, wieder nicht im Mai, aber zumindest in den Monaten, dann ist City, glaube ich, immer noch Master-Dinge.
Hat das eine Bedeutung, dass wir mit City und Chelsea zwei Mannschaften haben, die sich genau diesen klassischen Mittelstürmer geholt haben? Also bei Kane kann man jetzt noch, also bei beiden muss man Abstriche machen, Lukaku, weil er als Wandspieler sehr gut eingebunden werden kann, Kane, weil er sich auch häufiger mal fallen lässt. Aber würdest du da mehr rein interpretieren als jetzt bloß den zeitlichen Zufall, dass das beides zusammenfällt?
Nee, ich glaube aber sowieso, ich habe nie dran geglaubt, dass die echte Neuner ausgestorben ist. Sondern das liegt, glaube ich, einfach nur an der nicht vorhandenen Artenvielfalt. Wenn es die gäbe, dann hätten ganz viele Teams einen echten Neuner vorne drin, in Anführungszeichen. Und deswegen halte ich das nicht für einen Zufall, sondern gerade in dieser Premier League, in der die kleinen Teams vor allen Dingen noch Oldschool-Innenverteidiger drin stehen haben, die 1,90 und größer sind, und rund 100 Kilo mitschleppen, brauchst du halt sowas auch. Und wenn die dann auch noch Fußball spielen können oder intelligent sind, Lukaku ist ja in allererster Linie ein unheimlich intelligenter Fußballspieler, dann ist das für mich ein Match.
Lyon sucht auch gerade Hendrik nach einem Neuner. Wie ist denn der Transfermarkt gelaufen in England? Weil ich in Frankreich durchaus beobachtet habe, was mir in der Bundesliga auch aufgefallen ist, dass viele Vereine kaufen wollen, aber nicht verkaufen können, dass insgesamt irgendwie zu wenig Geld im Markt ist.
Wie immer ist England die Ausnahme. Also erstens haben wir noch nicht mal die Hälfte erlebt, von dem, was passieren wird. Ich glaube, dass ich habe so ziemlich bei jedem Team noch mindestens eine Transaktion und zwar eine größere Transaktion. Aber grundsätzlich ist England, also die Liga, sehr viel schlauer geworden. Die meisten Teams aus Southampton, da haben wir ja auch im Vorfeld zum Paris-Spiel oder Brest-Spiel gesprochen, David und ich. Oder er hat zu mir gesprochen, ich habe zugehört. So war es richtig, dass die z.B. Perot geholt haben, Southampton. Und so machen die es jetzt die ganze Zeit. Also diese sogenannten Reputationsmärkte, die sind voll abgegrast. Das Scouting der Engländer ist in Frankreich, in den Niederlanden, ist in Deutschland auch. Die zählen sie auch zu einem billigen Markt aus ihrer Sicht dazu. Und da sind sie sehr viel cleverer geworden. Und das macht die Teams einfach viel breiter und viel stärker nochmal. Die Salzburger haben zwei Spieler verloren, nach England, Wepo und Dakar, die beide voll funktionieren werden. Da habe ich überhaupt keinen Zweifel dran. Also daran sieht man zum einen das, was die Liga ist und dann sind natürlich auch noch die irren Sachen mit dabei, so wie ein Jack Grealish für 100 Millionen. Aber grundsätzlich ist die Liga sehr viel cleverer geworden im Recruitment.
Aktuell Ausgabeneinnahmen laut transfermarkt.de über eine Milliarde hat man jetzt schon ausgegeben. Rund 500 Millionen eingenommen, Transfer-Saldo von minus 500. Und nur um das kurz in Bezug zu setzen zu anderen, liegen der Saldo von den großen Konkurrenten. Der liegt deutlich drunter. Die Ligue 1 ist mit minus 60 im Saldo schon die Anführerin. Die Serie A bei minus 30 Millionen Euro. Da muss man schon lange scrollen, um überhaupt zur Bundesliga zu kommen. Waschen hat mit dem TV-Geld zu tun, also muss man nicht dramatisieren. Aber es ist interessant, was sich da verändert hat. Ich glaube allerdings, dass du vorhin etwas gesagt hast, wo dann manche Leute kurz aufgehört haben. Nämlich, dass du Liverpool rausgenommen hast, aus der absoluten Spitze. Hängt das auch mit Transfers oder eben nicht vollzogenen Transfers zusammen?
Ja, wenn ich so will, ja. Ich habe vor allen Dingen ein Fragezeichen bei Liverpool. Das hatte ich auch schon letztes Jahr dastehen. Der Kern der Mannschaft ist so um die 30 jetzt. Das muss noch nicht schlimm sein. Wenn ich mir aber dann vor allen Dingen das Mittelfeld ansehe, Wijnaldum ist weg, tut sehr viel mehr weh, als man denkt. Der ist weg und das ist der Einzige, der nie verletzt war in den letzten Jahren. Fabinho hatte größere Probleme, Henderson sowieso. Bei dem ist man sicher noch nicht mal ganz sicher, ob es da nicht was Größeres hat. Deswegen haben wir auch die Vertragsverlängerungen so gestockt mit ihm. Und Müller wird jetzt auch nicht jünger. Er sieht so aus, als wäre er immer noch 28, aber er wird nicht jünger. Irgendwann muss es einfach mal passieren. Thiago ist auch keiner, den ich für 30 spiele oder vielleicht sogar 25 einplane, auch noch nicht so funktioniert hat. Und das ist die Sorge, die ich habe. Was, wenn was passiert? Dann können sie so nicht reagieren. Weiterhin die Torgefahr aus dem Mittelfeld für Minuswerte werden immer schlechter. Und ich meine jetzt noch nicht so sehr die Torwerte. Das hat, glaube ich, auch jeder und jeder begriffen, dass das so ist, dass er nicht in allererster Linie für das Toreschießen bezahlt wird, aber auch die Pressingwerte bei ihm werden schlechter. Und so habe ich insgesamt minimal weniger Vertrauen in Liverpool als in den Jahren zuvor. Also gut, letzte Saison, da war unbeschreibliches dabei. So ist es halt nun mal. Und dann aber trotzdem, auch wenn sie gesund waren, war es nicht die gleiche Kapelle wie im Vorjahr. Die sind jetzt nicht dramatisch mies, aber ich habe sie nicht als totalen Meisterschaftsfavoriten.
Und was ist mit United, die ja auch auf dem Transfermarkt, unter anderem ja mit Jaden Sancho zugegriffen haben?
Also es sollten Click and Rush-Hörerinnen oder Hörer anwesend sein, kennen sie die Antwort. Solange Uli Gunnar Soscha da ist, glaube ich an gar nichts.
Ist das immer noch die Antwort?
Ja, der hat einen solchen Kader, mit dem man so viele Dinge machen könnte, und er macht sie nicht. Das tut mir so leid, weil die Truppe ist gut bis sehr gut. Also in manchen Punkten sogar überragend, aber es ist immer noch kein offensiver Plan erkennbar. Das reicht. In der Liga, in der du gegen Pep Guardiola spielst, oder eben auch gegen Jürgen Klopp, oder gegen Luis Miritos Santo, oder Ralf Hasenhütl, reicht es nicht.
Ralf Hasenhütl habe ich jetzt deswegen reingeworfen, weil das war das letzte Spiel von United, und das war eben 1 zu 1 bei Southampton. Das war so eins dieser Ergebnisse, dass man liest, ohne das Spiel gesehen zu haben, und man sich nicht komplett wundert. Man denkt sich, das ist so typisch United, dass man dann gegen eine sehr gut organisierte, vermutlich, Mannschaft von Ralf Hasenhütl es dann eben nicht schafft zu gewinnen. Da fehlen dann eben schon die ersten Pünktchen wieder. Ich hoffe, ich liege da mit meiner Blinddiagnose nicht komplett daneben.
Ja, gut, es gab auch in der Vorsaison 9-0 von United gegen Southampton. Aber in dem Spiel lief es so ähnlich. Giftiges, gut organisiertes Southampton, und das sind so die Dinge, die United halt ungern mag, wenn der Gegner organisiert tief steht. Und das ist das, was ich genau meine. Dann gibt es halt immer noch keine Positionsspielvarianten, die sowas dann auseinanderziehen. Irgendwann reicht es mir jetzt auch mal nach drei, dreieinhalb Jahren an Potenzial oder sowas zu appellieren, sondern jetzt muss dann auch mal was passieren.
Aijajaj, Arsenal mit Problemen auf der Trainerposition United kann man dazu rechnen. Ich weiß nicht, über wen du gerne noch sprechen wollen würdest. Wir haben noch nicht über die Spurs gesprochen. Wir haben auch noch gar nicht über Brentford oder andere Aufsteiger oder Underdog-Teams gesprochen. League United, logischerweise auch immer ein Thema. Allein schon wegen Bielsa. Wen würdest du gerne noch kurz erwähnen?
Also, Brentford liegt mir schon auch am Herzen, weil ich alles spannend finde. Die haben diesen etwas datenbasierteren Ansatz. Man sagt gemein immer Moneyball. Das ist immer sehr, sehr simpel erklärt. Aber die sind schon noch mal kreativer als andere in der Spielerfindung. Sehr, sehr datenorientiert. Den genauen Algorithmus geben sie nicht raus. Ich war kurz vor Covid da auch in Brentford, noch im alten Stadion. Damals, Gott sei Dank, konnte ich das noch machen, bevor es dann abgerissen wurde. Inzwischen ist es ja weg. Und habe mit Thomas Frank eine Zeit lang sprechen können, dem Trainer, hochspannender Typ, richtiger Kommunikator, einfühlsamer, eher ein Supervisor, der wirklich noch den klassischen englischen Weg geht und seine Stärken nicht im Training hat, sondern eher in der Spieler-Mannschaftsführung. Und entsprechend dann auch verteilt mit einem Kader mit ein, zwei hochinteressanten Spielern. Bumeaux, glaube ich, ist eh ein Begriff inzwischen. Das ist ein spannendes Team. Und ich stehe auch persönlich ein bisschen auf Brighton, weil Graham Potter wirklich auch einen ballbesitzorientierten Fußball spielen lässt. Und wenn der gut gemacht ist, ist er nach wie vor nicht out. Wenn man manchmal Gegenteiliges vermuten könnte. Die spielen echt von hinten raus, versuchen mit interessanten, jungen, spielstarken Spielern ein Spiel aufzuziehen. Haben aber dazu zwei, drei Maschinen im Zentrum drin. Die sehe ich auch sehr, sehr gerne. Das ist so ein persönlicher Darling von mir.
Ach Mensch, jetzt weiß ich wieder, wie das immer war, als wir die internationale Kurzperse gemacht haben. Ich bekomme Lust, jede Liga zu gucken. Aber ich schaffe das nicht. Das ist ja fürchterlich. Aber ja, Brentford und Brighton, die sollte man sich auf jeden Fall mal angucken. An dieser Stelle, bevor wir über La Liga sprechen, David hat gesagt, ne, spanischen Fußball, da möchte ich nicht mehr mit dabei sein. David hat noch einen Anschlusstermin. David, ich danke dir sehr, dass du mit dabei warst. David Frogier de Ponlevoy, et un gungong vn auf Twitter, ich werde es verlinken und bei 93 kann man dich auch hören. Danke David, dass du hier warst.
Genau, es war großartig, es hat ganz viel Spaß gemacht. Ich gehe mit einem weinen Auge, aber ich muss leider weiter. Aber euch viel Spaß und hoffentlich auf dem nächsten Mal.
Kannst einfach auflegen, ciao. Und wir machen an der Stelle weiter mit eben La Liga. Das kommt jetzt wie aus dem Nichts für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Auch da sind zwei Spieltage schon vorbei. Da gibt es mehrere Themen. Ich weiß es gar nicht. Möchtest du mit dem Sportlichen beginnen, Alex, oder müssen wir dann doch erst mal noch über das, was wirtschaftlich zwischen dem Verband und den Mannschaften mit Real, mit Barca alles passiert ist, wie wollen wir beginnen? Gut, dann, nachdem wir erst zwei Spieltage gesehen haben und dass dann ja dann doch immer die Aussagekräfte noch nicht so groß ist wie später, dann lass mal mit den tektonischen Verschiebungen beginnen. Also wir haben eine Präsidentschaftswahl bei Barca gehabt. Wir wissen auch, dass da ja auch dein besonderes Interesse liegt bei Barca. Und danach unglaubliche Zahlen, die da genannt wurden, eine Verschuldung von 1,3 Milliarden Euro. Am Ende konnte Messi nicht gehalten werden. Da gibt es jetzt auch verschiedene Theorien zu, ob es vielleicht, also ob man nicht wollte oder ob auch das spanische Recht damit dazu ging, weil er nicht, weil er sein Minimumgehalt 50 Prozent gewesen wäre. Und selbst das wären 95 Prozent der Personalausgaben gewesen, die erlaubt gewesen wären für Barca. Die Situation, sie sieht von außen sehr dramatisch aus. Gibt es da irgendwelche Hoffnungsschimmerchen, die ich übersehe?
Es gibt Hoffnungsschimmer, in denen der Verein einfach sehr, sehr umsatzstark ist. Nämlich der umsatzstärkste Verein der letzten zwei, drei Jahre weltweit. Das ist einfach der größte Hoffnungsschimmer für alle Anhänger des FC Barcelona, für die Vereinsverantwortlichen natürlich auch, diese katastrophale Finanzsituation umzukehren. Denn wenn keine Pandemie wäre, nehmen sie rund eine Milliarde Euro ein. Und das ist einfach der große Hoffnungsschimmer, dass sich der Verein einfach in zwei, drei Jahren wieder konsolidiert.
Aber die hat man ja auch mit Messi eingenommen. Weiß man, wie hoch da der Messi-Anteil ist?
Das ist tatsächlich ein guter Einwand. Natürlich hast du die eingenommen, weil du Messi hattest. Also sportlich natürlich außergewöhnlich gut warst, zumindest in der Liga in den meisten Jahren. Und natürlich dieses Aushängeschild hattest, das auch Sponsoring, Marketing etc. natürlich stark beeinflusst. Genaue Zahlen gibt es ja natürlich nicht. Aber ja, man könnte durchaus davon ausgehen, dass es da gewisse Einbrüche gibt oder gewisse Firmen etwas weniger offerieren an Marketing-Sponsoring-Einnahmen. Jetzt, wo der sechsmalige Weltfußballer, der vielleicht beste Fußballer aller Zeiten, nicht mehr in deinem Verein ist. Also natürlich ist das sportlich ein Schlag vor den Bug, ein Tiefschlag, aber natürlich auch marketingtechnisch, sponsorentechnisch.
Du als langjähriger Beobachter von Barca, war denn für dich das Ausmaß überraschend?
Das Finanzielle, meinst du jetzt? Das kam dahingehend nicht überraschend, weil es ja über viele, viele Monate kommuniziert wurde. Also auch wir bei Barca World covern das ja sowieso. Dementsprechend überrascht einen ja eher weniger, weil wir daily da den Finger drauf haben. Aber auch die Bartomeo-Riege, also Ex-Präsident Josette Maria Bartomeo, war da recht offen. Auch wenn er nicht immer sehr, sehr ehrlich und offen ist. Aber in dem Fall bezüglich der Zahlen war das schon im, ja sogar im Herbst, meine ich, im Herbst 2020, dass er da eben gesagt hat, Corona hat uns so, so hart getroffen, weil Ticketing wegfällt, keine Zuschauer im Stadion waren. Und vor allem, was Barca ziemlich hart betrifft, ist, dass das Museum und der Fanshop zu hatten. Das sind einfach große Einnahmen, die Barca da entging, weil jeder, der in Barcelona mal als Tourist war, weiß, dieses Museum, das ist einfach das A und O dieses Vereins bezüglich der Einnahmen vor Ort jedenfalls. Und in dem Moment, wo einer zum anderen kommt, bricht einfach Barca so, so viel Geld weg. Plus natürlich die generelle Misswirtschaft, die Bartomeu und Co. gemacht haben. Deswegen war es nicht überraschend, weil der Verein da recht transparent war tatsächlich.
Kleiner Fun-Fact dazu, die Ultras der Bayern haben immer mal wieder an Uli Hoeneß herangetragen, ob man nicht auch ein Bayernmuseum gründen wollen würde. Und er war da immer relativ neutral, sag ich jetzt mal, gegenüber eingestellt. Und als er dann, gerüchteweise zumindest, habe ich das gehört, als er dann gehört hat, was Barcelona für einen Umsatz macht mit seinem Museum, dann war es auf einmal beschlossen, es gibt jetzt die FC Bayern World. Also wie gesagt, das habe ich nur aus einer Quelle gehört, ist jetzt aber auch nicht komplett out of character.
Es sind wirklich viele hunderte Millionen Euro. Also die genaue Zahl, da kannst du mich jetzt nicht drauf festnageln, da müsste ich jetzt die Bilanz nochmal checken von Barca. Aber es sind wirklich exorbitante Summen, die der FC Barcelona wirklich nur durch die Stadion tut, durch das Museum und dann den Fanshop, wo man reinläuft, einnimmt. Und ja, das ist eben weggebrochen ein Jahr, eineinhalb Jahre lang. Und das ist auch ein Grund von vielen, vielen Gründen, warum Barca diese 1,3 Milliarden Schulden hat.
Ach, Wahnsinn, ey. Was ist das für eine Fußballwelt, dass man allein dadurch so viel umsetzen kann? Aber es ist halt ein geiler Sport.
Darf ich mal eine Zwischenfrage stellen? Wäre das denn nicht zum Beispiel möglich gewesen, dass Barca zumindest Messi pro forma noch mal zur Vertragsunterschrift bringt, um dann wenigstens eine Ablösesumme zu generieren? Sign and Trade würde man ja aus der amerikanischen Sportwelt dann vielleicht einführen können als Begriff. Puh, schwierig, weil da gibt es ja natürlich unterschiedliche Aussagen. Max hat ja dieses Arbeitsrecht, das Spanische, angesprochen. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel da dran ist. Ich habe nämlich unterschiedliche Berichte gelesen. Zum einen hieß es natürlich mehr als 50% deines Gehalts. Darauf darfst du nicht verzichten. Weniger darfst du nicht kassieren. Spanisches Arbeitsrecht. Ich habe aber genauso gelesen, dass es Berichte gab, die besagen, im Fußball gilt das Arbeitsrecht nicht, weil ja jeder jeden Vertrag unterschreiben kann, wie er möchte. Du kannst ja den Fußballer nicht mit der Putzfrau vergleichen. Deswegen kann ich dir das nicht final beantworten, ob er auch für 3 Millionen Euro unterschreiben hätte können. Oder ob er wirklich genau 50% und keinen Cent weniger kassieren darf. Das weiß ich leider nicht, weil ich beides gelesen habe. Und so tief im Arbeitsrecht steckt leider keiner von uns.
Aber es ist ja schon interessant, dass es im Nachhinein unterschiedliche Aussagen zu gibt. Das muss vielleicht auch einfach so sein. Weil der Wechsel halt auch so überraschend und so groß war.
Und undurchsichtig natürlich bis heute, muss man auch sagen. Man weiß auch nicht, kommt es Barca gar nicht so ungelegen, dass er weg ist? Weil selbst wenn sie ihn behalten hätten für kolportierte 40 Millionen Brutto pro Jahr, was ja die Hälfte von seinem letzten Basisgehalt war, auch das hätte ja Barca, wäre ein enormer Klotz im Bein gewesen. Denn man wusste ja, Messi möchte maximal 2 Jahre, vielleicht 3 bleiben. Laporta hat das ganz, ganz aktiv, offensiv kommuniziert. Es wäre einfach nur 2 Jahre mehr Messi gewesen. Lohnt sich das finanziell in der Situation, wo Barca ist, für nur 2 Jahre Messi 40 Brutto zu geben, plus natürlich, sie hätten es gestreckt über 5 Jahre. Also es wären ja nicht nur die 40, sprich 80 gewesen, sondern sie hätten das Gehalt ja gestückelt auf 5 Jahre. Von daher gibt es auch Stimmen, die sagen, so finanziell unrecht kommt das dem Verein gar nicht, weil man eben dieses exorbitante Gehalt jetzt spart. Ich finde es auch sportlich gar nicht so schlecht. Da widerspreche ich stark, aber ich wollte sagen, es ist sehr undurchsichtig. Es gibt viele Berichte, viele Sichtweisen. Final kann man das, glaube ich, einfach nicht klären. Da könntest du noch 3 Stunden drüber reden, über diese Causa.
Aber das Sportliche finde ich sogar interessanter. Da könnt ihr euch gerne gegenseitig die Argumente um die Ohren hauen. Uli, lass mal vorlegen. Warum glaubst du, dass es auch sportlich gar nicht so schlecht ist, jetzt vor Messi loszukommen?
Bei Barca, wenn Messi drauf war, alle Werte schlechter mit Messi. Außer die erzielten Tore am Ende. Aber der Rest der Werte sind schlechter. Wenn du jetzt hinbekommst, dass du die Tore anderswoher kriegst, und ich habe großes Vertrauen in den Talentpool, den Barca da hat, weil Minus Breathrate vielleicht, aber ansonsten habe ich großes Vertrauen, dann glaube ich, dass die das hinkriegen. Dann hast du endlich mal wieder eigene Entscheidungsgewalt über den Kader und über alles, was sonst so passiert. Auch auf dem Spielfeld war... Ich weiß schon, dass Lionel Messi ziemlich begnadet ist. Das ist mir schon klar. Dass er im letzten Halbjahr wieder gezeigt hat, wo es herkommt. Davor war auch ein halbes, dreiviertel Jahr, wo er kein Bock hatte und das auch klar gezeigt hat. Und auch, glaube ich, jüngere Spieler, zumindest die, die nicht in seinem Kreis zählt, eher in der Entwicklung gehemmt hat. Und das ist jetzt halt endlich mal weg. Also der große, große Elefant ist raus. Und jetzt können auch andere mal einen Schritt nach vorne machen. Und ich traue es denen zu, den Petris und so, dass die das machen. Da stimme ich dir tatsächlich zu, dass andere einen Schritt nach vorne machen können, dass andere mehr Verantwortung übernehmen können, dass sie einfach größere Rollen auf dem Platz spielerisch einnehmen können. Allen voran Frenkie de Jong beispielsweise und Antoine Griezmann. Der Jong hat das selbst in einem Interview, ich meine vor einer Woche oder so, gesagt, dass sobald du im Mittelfeld den Ball bekommst, du schaust direkt, wo ist Messi auf dem Platz positioniert und gibst ihm den Ball weiter. Also völlig unabhängig davon, ob das in dem Fall der beste Pass ist, die beste Aktion für deinen Spielzug, du schaust, wo ist Messi und gibst ihm den Ball. Weil er diesen Ball fordert mit Körperspare, aufgrund des Elefants, wie du ihn nennst. Der ist einfach in diesem Verein und auf dem Platz natürlich. Und das ist ja natürlich auch nicht immer so gut für eine Mannschaft, dass jeder Ball immer zu Messi geht. Egal, wo er steht, egal, wie die Situation ist. Davon kann Barca wirklich profitieren, dass andere Spieler mehr Verantwortung übernehmen, sich mehr auf dem Spielfeld ausleben können, größere Rollen einnehmen. Grießmann ist da auch ein sehr prominentes Beispiel, der einfach nicht der Grießmann war, den man kennt einfach, weil er auch diese Freiheiten benötigt, sich gern ins Mittelfeld fallen lässt. Und mehr oder weniger verloren war, fand ich immer, wenn Messi auf dem Platz war. Meistens in sieben von zehn Spielen. Da gebe ich dir recht, Uli, der Rest der Mannschaft kann eine größere Rolle einnehmen, aber es fehlt trotzdem der mit Abstand beste Fußballer aller Zeiten der Welt.
Das waren viele Spiele. Ein schwaches Argument, ganz ehrlich. Jetzt haben wir schon zwei Spiele von Barca gesehen. Wenn man so will, könnte man da schon von Problemen sprechen. Es gab zwar einen Sieg im Auftakt gegen Real Sociedad, 4 zu 2, aber jetzt ein Unentschieden gegen Athletic Bilbao. In beiden Partien hatte Barca den Ball, nicht wirklich überraschend, aber gegen Real Sociedad 13 Schüsse herausgespielt, gegen Athletic Bilbao nur 9. Das ist einer der schlechtesten Werte, die ich in längerer Zeit für Barca gesehen habe. Ist das jetzt eine Überinterpretation meinerseits? Wenn ich da jetzt schon sage, da sieht man vielleicht dann auch schon die ersten Probleme. Hängt das mit dem frühen Zeitpunkt der Saison zusammen? Wie würdest du das erklären, Alex?
Ich würde leider sagen, ja, es ist eine Überinterpretation deinerseits. Ich glaube, man muss die Spiele für sich betrachten. Gegen Real Sociedad, da war der Gegner sehr schwach. Barca sehr motiviert allein durch die Rückkehr der Fans. Erstes Heimspiel nach 1,5 Jahren vor Fans. Und Barca hat da wirklich diesen Wir-wollen-s-allen-zeigen-jetzt-wo-messi-weg-effekt sehr gut auf den Platz gebracht von der ersten Minute an. Hat verdient geführt gegen einen Gegner, der schwach war, und hat dann locker gewonnen. Sprich, diese recht wenigen Torschüsse waren nicht nötig, weil sie irgendwann 2-0, 3-0 führten. Und dann Barca typisch in einem Heimspiel den Fuß vom Gas genommen haben. Und in Bilbao, das ist jetzt das zweite Spiel, die zweite Story, war es einfach so, dass diese Basken in einem Heimspiel den gleichen Effekt hatten. Erstes Heimspiel im San Mamés vor Fans, die waren 150% motiviert, wie sie es sowieso sehr, sehr oft sind in Heimspielen gegen Top-Teams. Also da hast du diesen, ich nenne es einfach mal spanischen Effekt, wo du dir denkst, so mittelmäßige Clubs, wenn sie gegeneinander gegen andere mittelmäßige Clubs spielen, sind sie aus irgendeinem Grund nicht so angefixt, nicht so motiviert. Und sobald Barca real Atletico kommen, geben sie einfach 20, 30, 50 Prozent mehr. Diesen Effekt, fand ich, gab es sichtlich im Spiel. Auch mit Messi hätte Barca, um zu deinem Punkt zu kommen, nicht besser ausgesehen bei Atletico Bebaue und hätte kein besseres Spiel gemacht, weil es ein typisches Spiel des FC Barcelona im San Marmes war, wo die Hausherren einfach anrennen wie von der Tarantel gestochen.
Ja, deswegen haben wir dich ja als Experten hier und nicht mich. Und war das...
So meinte ich es jetzt gar nicht, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, alles gut. Ich kann das gar nicht wissen. Ich kann diese Spiele nicht gucken. Ich muss da spekulieren. Deswegen müsst ihr mich da einordnen. Wie ist denn dann das 3 zu 3 von Real bei Levante zu bewerten, was ja ein höchst spektakuläres Spiel war? Also jeder, der die Zeit hat, dem empfehle ich noch mal so ab Minute 75 die Aufzeichnung von der Zone sich noch mal reinzuziehen und vielleicht jetzt dann zwei Minuten zu skippen, damit man nicht gespoilert wird. Aber da ging es ja auch hoch her zwischen Levante und Real.
Das war eines dieser komischen Spiele, das man nicht erklären kann. Also Bilbao gegen Barca kannst du wirklich erklären, weil das wiederkehrend ist, dass die Basken gegen Top-Teams zu Hause anrennen wie verrückt. Levante gegen Real Madrid ist eins dieser Spiele, das du nicht erklären kannst. Auch so ein typisch spanisches Spiel, wo du dir denkst, der Favorit hat alles im Griff. In der ersten Halbzeit führte Real 1-0 und Levante war wirklich chancenlos, hat körperlos agiert, in der Abwehr stimmte nichts. Und du dachtest, wenn das so weitergeht, endet es halt 3-0, 4-0, 5-0 für Real. Und zwar hoch verdient. Plötzlich wurde aus dem Nichts zur Halbzeit irgendwo ein Hebel umgesetzt, umgelegt. Und Levante schoss aus dem Nichts ein, zwei Tore und hatte dann plötzlich Oberwasser. Und du wusstest nicht, woher das kommt. Hat natürlich der Trainer von Levante die richtigen Worte gefunden. Oder hat sich Real gedacht, das wird locker. Hier der Gegner ist so schwach, wir können das auch easy im dritten Gang runterspielen. Wahrscheinlich stimmt beides und dann kommt eins zum anderen. Aber es war nicht vorhersehbar, dass das Spiel so eskaliert. Ja, völlig verrückte Partie, wilde Partie. Und wie das im Fußball halt dann so ist, manchmal schaukelt es sich hoch. Fans im Stadion, glaube ich in Spanien, tun da noch mal ein bisschen was ihr Übriges, weil die Spanier das ja überhaupt nicht mehr gewohnt sind. Also ja, es war ein absolut wildes, unerklärliches Spiel.
Also Levante hat das gedreht bis zur 57. Minute. Vinicius Junior dann ausgeglichen, der 73. in der 79. erneute Führung für Levante. In der 85. Ausgleich von Vinicius durch ein entweder Geniestreich oder schiefgegangene Reingabe, so oder so, was einfach ein wunderschöner Treffer. Und dann natürlich musste da noch was passieren. In der 87. Minute muss Aitor Fernandes einen Ball mit der Hand gegen Vinicius kurz hinter der Mittellinie klären. Sie sieht dafür die rote Karte. Ein Feldspieler muss zwischen die Pfosten gehen, weil Levante schon fünfmal gewechselt hat. Real schafft es aber nicht. Ich glaube, die haben kein einziges Mal mehr aufs Tor geschossen in dieser Phase. Hat mich wundert, dass da nicht einer einfach mal abgezogen hat. Aber es war hochdramatisch mit sechs, sieben Minuten Nachspielzeit wirklich sehr schön, noch mal nachzusehen. Hab ich gestern Nacht auch gemacht.
Das war übrigens auch ein typisches Levantespiel, wenn die gegen die großen spielen. Ein bisschen ähnlich wie bei Athletic Bilbao. Die sind einfach wirklich noch mal motivierter. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die nur sie kennen. Also wenn Levante gegen, sagen wir, Rayo Valle Cano, Ossasuna oder Retafe spielt, brauchst du dir diese Spiele gar nicht ansehen. Du kannst vorab mit einer 70%igen Wahrscheinlichkeit 0-0 oder 1-1 prognostizieren. Und sobald sie aber gegen Real Barca und Athletico spielen, sind sie unberechenbar. Beispiel nicht nur dieses 3 zu 3 jetzt, also gestern. Letzte Saison gegen Barcelona auch ein 3 zu 3 zu Hause. Da lagen sie sogar 0 zu 2 hinten, waren eigentlich auch chancenlos. Im Wandermetropolitano bei Athletico hat Levante 2-0 gewonnen. Und bei Real Madrid, im Di Stefano, hat Levante 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Also absolut verrückte Ergebnisse für die Mannschaft, die eigentlich eine graue Maus ist und die nie besser als Platz 9 oder Platz 12 in Spanien ist. Aber gegen die großen drei sind sie aus irgendwelchen Gründen immer top motiviert und spielen ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste, wenn man so will. Also nichts zu verlieren und stürmen drauf los und überraschen die Großen immer wieder.
Na ja, Augsburg gewinnt ja auch hin und wieder gegen den BVB. Das ist nicht so komplett unbekannt und ist ansonsten dann doch manchmal grauer als grau, möchte man fast schon sagen. Wir sind schon am Ende angelangt. Gibt es noch eine Mannschaft oder etwas, was du uns noch erklären wirst, was jetzt in den ersten zwei Spieltagen völlig überraschend war? Oder läuft La Liga halt einfach so los und man muss dann in ein paar Spieltagen noch mal genauer drauf gucken?
Tatsächlich gibt es bisher aus meiner Sicht nichts Überraschendes. Die Top 3, gut, zwei Spiele gespielt, nicht mal alle Partien absolviert, aber die Top 3 sind wie letztes Jahr, Atletico, Real Barca, sogar in der identischen Reihenfolge. Obwohl, zwei Patzer es schon gab, von Real und Barca, beide nur unentschieden, das kommt so ein bisschen vielleicht überraschend für den einen oder anderen, aber gänzlich ja auch nicht, wenn man ehrlich ist, weil beide Vereine einfach jetzt seit, ich würde sogar sagen, drei Jahren nicht mehr das allerhöchste europäische Niveau haben. Sprich, die werden immer wieder, vor allem in Auswärtsspielen, Punkte lassen. Und Atletico macht Atletico-Dinge. Ein 2-1, ein Dusel 2-1 bei Celta und jetzt ein sehr, sehr langweiliges 1-0 gegen Elche, wo gefühlt wirklich gar nichts passiert ist, außer dem Siegtuor von Atletico. Das war schön, aber ansonsten typisches Atletico-Spiel.
Gut, Business as Usual in Spanien, Business as Unusual hier im Rasenfunk. Ein neues Format. Ich habe komplett den Überblick verloren, bei wie viel Minuten Laufzeit wir jetzt sind. Denn wir hatten zwischendurch technische Probleme. Wenn ihr nichts davon gehört habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann hat nicht nur Uli 3-mal wirklich perfekt dieselbe Antwort gegeben, sondern wir haben auch sonstige technische Probleme noch irgendwie eliminiert bekommen. Ich danke euch beiden ganz, ganz herzlich und stellvertretend auch noch mal, David. Einmal Uli Hebel von Dazorn und Sky. Add Uli Hebel auf Twitter. Danke dir, Uli, dass du mit dabei warst bei dieser Premiere. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an Alex Truica. Man kann ihn hören im Tikitaka-Podcast. Unter anderem, man kann ihn lesen bei barcawelt.de. Man kann ihm auf Twitter folgen. Da heißt er, add Alex Truica. Alles maximal einfach. Danke dir, Alex, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr gerne.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Wenn alles nach Plan verläuft, dann werden wir in der nächsten Woche hier über die zweite Bundesliga der Männer sprechen. Und dann gucken wir mal, in welcher Taktung diese Ligatur hier dann kommen wird und wie wir das genau gestalten. Gebt uns gerne Feedback. Auf mitmachen.rasen.de ist dafür die Gelegenheit. Freue mich auf den nächsten Rasen vom Kurzpass. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, passt auf euch auf, bis bald, ciao!